THAT AND SO MUCH MORE IS ALL
AHEAD.
>>> WE DO BEGIN THIS MORNING
WITH RENEWED QUESTIONS OVER
SECURITY AT THE U.S. CAPITOL
FOLLOWING A DEADLY ATTACK FRIDAY
AFTERNOON.
A CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER WAS
KILLED, ANOTHER HURT AFTER A MAN
RAM WANTED HIS CAR INTO A
BARRICADE STEPS FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING.
THE SUSPECT EMERGED FROM THE CAR
WITH A KNIFE AND WAS SHOT AND
KILLED.
EVEN WITH MOST LAWMAKERS GONE
FOR THE HOLIDAY WEEKEND, THE
CAPITOL COMPLEX WAS LOCKED DOWN
FOR HOURS.
IT COMES DAYS AFTER SOME
SECURITY MEASURES PUT IN PLACE
AFTER THE DEADLY JANUARY 6th
RIOTS WERE SCALED BACK.
JEFF PEGUES IS IN OUR WASHINGTON
NEWSROOM WITH MORE.
JEFF, GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
FLAGS AT THE CAPITOL ARE AT HALF
STAFF TODAY IN HONOR OF THE
FALLEN OFFICER, AN 18-YEAR
VETERAN OF THE CAPITOL POLICE
FORCE.
INVESTIGATORS SAY THIS INCIDENT
DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE A
TERRORIST ACT, AND THE SUSPECT
WAS NOT ON THE RADAR OF POLICE.
BUT IT IS RAISING QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW SECURE THE CAPITOL IS.
POLICE RUSHED TO THE SCENE
FRIDAY AFTERNOON.
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS STILL ON
DUTY AFTER THE JANUARY 6th RIOTS
FORMED A PHALANX FOR A WIDER
ATTACK THAT NEVER CAME.
IT WAS LIMITED TO THIS -- A
SINGLE BLUE SEDAN THAT RAN OVER
TWO CAPITOL HILL POLICE OFFICERS
BEFORE SMASHING INTO A
DEPLOYABLE BARRICADE.
POLICE SAY THE DRIVER,
25-YEAR-OLD NOAH GREEN, GOT OUT
WITH A KNIFE AND THEN ATTACKED
OFFICERS ON THE SCENE, STABBING
ONE IN THE FACE.
GREEN WAS SHOT AND LATER DIED AT
THE HOSPITAL.
IN RECENT SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS,
GREEN SAID THAT HE HAS BEEN
TRIED WITH SOME OF THE BIGGEST
UNIMAGINABLE TESTS IN HIS LIFE
AND WAS UNEMPLOYED.
HE WAS UNKNOWN TO INVESTIGATORS
BEFORE THE ATTACK.
>> WE DO NOT HAVE THE SUSPECT ON
FILE WITH U.S. CAPITOL POLICE.
SO THERE'S NO INDICATION AT THIS
TIME THAT THERE IS ANY NEXUS TO
ANY MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
>> Reporter: THE OFFICER KILLED
IN THE ATTACK HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS 41-YEAR-OLD
WILLIAM "BILLY" EVANS.
THE FATHER TWO OF JOINED THE
CAPITOL POLICE IN 2003 AND WAS A
MEMBER OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS
UNIT.
FAMILY FRIEND JASON LAFOREST.
>> BILLY KNEW FROM THE TIME HE
WAS IN COLLEGE HE AND ONE OF HIS
BEST FRIENDS ACTUALLY BECAME
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICERS
TOGETHER.
SO IT WAS A DREAM OF HIS IN
COLLEGE.
>> Reporter: POLICE OFFICERS
LINE THE STREETS OF D.C. IN
TRIBUTE AS THE PROCESSION PASSED
BY.
HIS DEATH COMES NEARLY THREE
MONTHS AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
ONE OFFICER, BRIAN SICKNICK, WAS
KILLED.
ANOTHER DIED BY SUICIDE IN THE
DAYS AFTER.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE.
I ASK THAT YOU KEEP OUR U.S.
CAPITOL POLICE FAMILY IN YOUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS.
>> YEAH, THIS RIPS THE SCAB OFF.
>> Reporter: OHIO CONGRESSMAN
TIM RYAN CHAIRS THE WHICH
OVERSEES THE CAPITOL POLICE.
LAWMAKERS HAVE BEEN ARGUING OVER
HOW MUCH SECURITY IS NEEDED AT
THE CAPITOL AFTER THE RIOTS.
>> THEY CAN'T FALL INTO THE
OTHER POLITICAL ARGUMENTS THAT
WE'RE HAVING.
THIS IS ABOUT THE SECURITY OF
THE NATION'S CAPITOL.
THAT'S THE TEMPLE OF DEMOCRACY.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID THAT HE IS HEARTBROKEN BY
THE ATTACK.
THE INJURED OFFICER IS
RECOVERING IN A HOSPITAL.
HE IS EXPECTED TO MAKE A FULL
RECOVERY.
WE LEARNED OVERNIGHT THAT
INVESTIGATORS ARE KEYING IN ON
WHETHER NOAH GREEN, THE SUSPECT,
HA